hi I'm Isaac himsa dry and I play brand
stock at the very start were introduced
to this very happy-go-lucky it's a very
vivacious little kid who likes climbing
around the castle walls and his greatest
desires to become a knight and which one
of you was a marksman at 10 he
practicing Brad Brad is probably your
pretty average medieval kid who's bought
into a noble family which sets us up for
some sadness in the future he's just
climbing around happily doing what he
does and stumbles across one of the
biggest secrets in Westeros at that time
which is the fact that the Queen and her
brother are having an incestuous
relationship stop stop and Cersei and
Jaime they're not gonna risk a little
kids putting their whole kingdom and
their whole rulership in jeopardy
things I do for love but the start of
season 7 bran is not really brown as we
know it he is he is properly the
three-eyed Raven there which means the
entire history of the world has been
downloaded into his head Brown is now a
vehicle for time and history and so when
he gets back to Winterfell and is
reunited initially with Sansa it's not
the beautiful stark reunion we were
hoping for because as bran says he
remembers what it was like to be bran
stark but he remembers so much else now
he just doesn't register emotions or
much like that anymore he just says and
explains what he sees as he sees it it's
like that every second he is existing in
so many different time periods he's
experienced in the world through so many
different people's eyes and so it kind
of turns his brain into something of a
computer and the three-eyed Raven I
don't know what that means it means I
can see everything
everything that ever happened to
everyone everything that's happening
right now and then he meets back up with
Aria and offers her this dagger that
Littlefinger had just given to him
previously are you sure it's variants
teal it's wasted on a he can
sort of sense that there's gonna be some
importance to this dagger and so as the
season goes on
Littlefinger's been missing the stark
sisters against each other and just as
we think Santa's gonna order the
execution of Aria we discover that she's
actually taken some consultation from
the world's biggest CCTV archive you
conspired with Cersei Lannister and
Joffrey Baratheon to betray our Father
Ned Stark do you deny it I deny it
none of you were there to see what
happened none of you knows the truth you
held a knife to his throat
you said I did warn you not to trust me
and he gets his comeuppance I mean
samwell tarly I wasn't sure if you'd
remember me I remember everything
samwell tarly pops in again they get
chatting and bran explains the true
situation of Jon Snow's parentage he's
the son of Rhaegar Targaryen and my aunt
Lyanna stop Sam oh no you're wrong I
transcribed a high septons diary he in
all Drago's marriage to earlier he would
only honor in a secret ceremony are you
certain it's what the High Septon wrote
in his private diary I don't know why
you'd lie in fact John is not an alleged
illegitimate child at all and Rhaegar
did not rape Liana they were in love
the whole rebellion was built on a lie
and John is actually the heir to the
Iron Throne and all of a sudden
everything gets very very complicated
because John and Daenerys are now in
love they're gonna wage battle together
and John is pledging his support for her
and by the end of season seven it's all
a bit uncertain hey everybody its
Charlie I got a lot of requests to do
videos for the other Game of Thrones
Season eight promos this one's for bran
stark he actually said some really cool
stuff he actually calls out Arya's
Valyrian dagger is being extremely
important so let's break it down there's
a new round of that Song of Ice and Fire
book giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video so this is a vastly
cut down version of the video they
released for his character I just tried
to include the really important stuff
there was some really cool stuff about
Hodor because he talks about breaking
the space-time continuum when he was in
the three-eyed Ravens cave but I think
the most important teaser that he drops
is for the Valyrian dagger when he gives
it to Arya he says he senses that is of
critical importance in the fight against
the night King in the White Walkers and
that Arya is supposed to have it we
spent a lot of time during season seven
trying to contextualize how the show was
using his abilities because it's a
little bit different than his powers in
the books I'll talk about that in a
second but he also clarifies that Arya
and Sansa know how to ask him questions
they might
fully understand what's going on with
him but they now realize that he has
perfect recall of everything that's
happened in the world so they use him to
find out what Littlefinger has really
been doing since the beginning just
because they suspect that he might be
doing something wrong they didn't really
know like they just sense that he was
trying to pit them against each other so
then knowing that bran remembers
everything they go to him and he tells
them what they want to know but the way
it works on the TV show is that you have
to ask him very specific questions so
they asked him what happened at King's
Landing with their father and that's why
he was able to reveal how he betrayed
Ned Stark
when Samwell came to speak to brand and
they reveal that Jon Snow's father is
Rhaegar Targaryen I think the reason why
bran didn't know about the unknown man
is one mostly because a plot like they
wanted the dramatic tension of Samwell
yes anding him like yes Jon Snow is the
son of Rhaegar Targaryen and it's much
bigger than that because Rhaegar
annulled his marriage to Elia Martell
and Wed Lyanna Stark then even though
bran doesn't really register emotions on
his face they both get really excited
and come to the conclusion that Jon Snow
is the heir to the Iron Throne of
Westeros at the same time but two if you
go by the books explanation of weirwood
visions which is what they call it when
Brandon the three-eyed Raven see through
time you could say that the ceremony
that Rhaegar and Lyanna had was
performed and recorded without any
weirwoods nearby in the books the way
the visions work is that they can only
see what the weirwoods have seen the
reason why they can see back thousands
of years to the creation of the night
king in the White Walkers is is because
their creation was performed next to a
weirwood in the trees lived for tens of
thousands of years so you're seeing
everything that the weirwoods across the
world have seen but the limitation is
like George our Martin is always careful
to build in limitations to abilities and
this also applies to Arya and her
faceless person skills is is that in the
case of the three-eyed Raven and brand
the weirwoods aren't in every city every
room every place on earth and people
have been cutting down the weirwoods for
thousands of years
that was what sparked the first war
between the children of the forest in
the first men that led to the creation
of the White Walkers so when the books
bran can only have visions so long as
there are still we're woods just imagine
that the weirwoods are like a cloud
storage database of all of world history
so if you cut off the where
was you cut off his access to the cloud
storage of memories
that's why brands spend so much time in
the godswood because that's where he's
most powerful is right next to a
weirwood I've done a lot of videos about
Aria's Valyrian dagger going all the way
back to the beginning of season seven
when we were talking about those
episodes and we saw it inside samwell's
book or at least a dagger that looked
identical to Arya's Valyrian dagger the
book was mostly about the Valerians and
the Targaryen sand how they would use
dragon glass and a lot of their designs
and the really interesting thing is is
that we don't know about the history of
the Valyrian dagger before Robert
Baratheon and Littlefinger it was called
the cat's-paws dagger because it was
given to the cat's paw by Joffrey but we
don't know its history prior to
Littlefinger there's a theory that at
one time it may have belonged to Rhaegar
Targaryen mostly because of the fact
that it had a giant Ruby in it and
typically Valyrian designs like that
didn't have a lot of rubies in them we
know the Rhaegar was obsessed with the
prophecy he's also a Targaryen so he had
access to a lot of Valyrian steel that
other normal wealthy families would not
he himself also one of the wealthiest
people in the kingdom could pay to have
a Valyrian weaponry fashioned from
another one as the crown prince he would
also have special access to the
forbidden sections of the archives in
the Citadel that Samwell has to steal
from later in the story the red
Targaryen sigil on his armors
breastplate was made out of rubies
that's why when George our Martin was
writing about the visions that were
being had of Rhaegar dying at the
Trident rubies go flying because Robert
smashed his breastplate in the rubies
flew out of it so it's thought that the
ruby may have been added to the hilt
much later the tv-show likes to pay off
big setups from earlier seasons so the
dagger during season 7 was obviously a
very big WTF moment in a big come up and
for Littlefinger's character but whether
or not George our Martin ever intends to
do this in the books it seems that the
TV show is intent on making the dagger
even bigger so initially you think the
dagger is just a really important thing
from season 1 but surprise it's probably
something that's been important in the
war for the dawn and the fight against
the night King for much much longer than
that
so the dagger becomes this device to
sort of bind all these separate things
that are happening on the TV show Jon
Snow Rhaegar Targaryen in the war for
dawn with the night king so let me know
in the comments bran stark himself is
saying that the dagger is of critical
importance in season 8 and it's
important that arya have it because
something really important is going to
happen let me know if you think he's
just talking about the war for the dawn
or if you also think that Arya is going
to kill Cersei with the Valyrian dagger
as well they dropped a whole bunch of
promos for all the main characters like
this so I will do videos for all those
other promos in the next week or so no
worries congratulations to Lottie you're
the giveaway winner from my last big
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your details
click here for the Jon Snow season 8
promo and click here for that Game of
Thrones season 8 teaser trailer thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome we'll see you guys tonight
you